now I had no idea how amazing clove is
for your body and so in this video I'm
going to share what would happen if you
consumed or chewed on one clove every
single day and when you chew it you
would want to just chew it up and then
just swallow it but clove is amazing I
found over 130 different patents on
clove with different applications
sometimes uh certain applications were
for your body other times it was for
like a natural fungicide for plants but
there's a lot of research on clove and
it's natural one of the most popular
ways that people use clove is as an like
a numbing agent if you have a a tooth
ache because it has analgesic properties
now when we talk about the benefits of
clove we're going to be talking about
the this essential oil in Clove called
yugal so you can also get yugal oil as
well but a lot of the benefits and the
the aromatic smell and taste is from
this oil and so this compound makes up
like 75 to 80% of that oil and there's a
lot of other Photon nutrients in there
as well one thing I like about using uh
natural herbs or spices is that you get
the whole package from nature it's not
an isolated compound like they would use
in drugs and by the way over 50% of all
drugs are derived from plant chemicals
usually they isolate them and then
synthesize them so they can then patent
them but there's some really fascinating
properties of clove I want to share with
you these properties are basically
defense mechanisms that the plant has
created over a long period of time to
keep itself alive and what would you
think would be the major attack on
plants if you mentioned microbes you are
correct so this is why clove has some
pretty powerful antimicrobial properties
antiviral antibacterial
anti-fungal
anti-candida anti-parasitic so this is
why it's very beneficial to have it in
your mouth simply because so many people
have an overgrowth of candida they might
have biofilms that turn into plaque they
might have some type of gum infection so
clove oil or just chewing in a clove
would be something I would recommend now
of course check with your doctor before
chewing on cloves because I'm not
claiming that this can cure you of any
medical diseases and if you do become
cured don't mention my name some people
even use the clove oil on their scalp
for problems of fungus or some pathogen
in some of the studies which I'll list
down below you'll see that uh it can
even help ruce the toxicity that's
created as a byproduct from fungus one
study I found that if you combine this
with an antibiotic it increases the Mis
value by 1,000% what does that mean mic
this relates to the lowest concentration
of an antibiotic at which bacterial
growth is completely inhibited that
means that you could use a lot less of
an antibiotic to create the effect and
as you know the more antibiotics you use
the more that you create super bugs
because you stress out these bugs you
kill a lot of them but then the ones
that don't die become super bugs and
they become resistant against that
stress from now on and they can pass on
their genes for resistance to other
microbes so just like in humans when we
go through stress uh many times we
become stronger so if we're talking
about
antimicrobial let's also talk about
antimicrobial inside our bodies there's
some research on how clove oil can help
with hpylori which is behind certain
types of ulcers and even gastritis well
clove happens to inhibit H pylori and
improve peptic ulcers and gastritis and
indigestion and gas and bloating but
other than that it doesn't really do
anything and I'm being very sarcastic
this phytonutrient in Clove also has the
effect of inhibiting something called
Mao so it's an MAO inhibitor which if
you look up an MAO inhibitor it's used
as an
anti-depressant where certain receptors
are inhibited so you have an increase of
nor adrenaline serotonin in dopamine we
also have an anti-inflammatory effect so
it's good for arthritis there's even
data on having properties anti- cancer a
specifically lung cancer now as far as
side effects from clove oil and talking
about the oil not the clove itself as
long as you stay below 2.4 mg per
kilogram of your weight and that's what
I like about spices and herbs and things
like that they're relatively safe
however you can always overdose on it if
you have too much of it it can create
some toxicity in your liver people uh
sometimes can be allergic to it and of
course you wouldn't want to take it if
you're pregnant or lactating but I
wanted to share with you um something
that's very very easy to do and it's
been around for like 3 ,000 years in
India it's been in China it has a long
history of therapeutic benefits now
since we talked about the benefits of
clove if you have not seen my video on
the benefits of garlic you should check
this video out right
here